Rubio quick out with Joe right back to
Ricky still pump up the green mustard
out the barrel and a home run ball early
for Ricky Rubio back on the floor this
five has not done much here to start the
third of the
any man from the Jazz Rubio to play
who relish these type of games no
question about they're gonna have to
raise their game to win this single
steps back three the pensive up shot
clock down to four
watch a movie on Mitchell's angles with
co-parent router
ah big one Ricky way to stay with it Oh
first six trick to the area of field
goals hold for four in the quarter for
New Orleans the Jazz have gone nine of
12 so far that that's the thing with the
chance boy you might get a couple on now
reveal the Miss Rose runs it Rubio the
former Teen Wolf put a hand in the
passing lane and comes up with the steal
he's still a fan favorite here in
Minnesota favors wide open tried to
force it inside and a turnover Utah turn
it over Denver Jazz get it right back
Rubio three Bank back and forth action
here a nice finds may win it Gobert with
the flush
Derrick Favors on the defensive end
tonight be an impact player Barnes lost
it favors tapped it away
try to find his shooting touch drives
baseline and around
Gobert stop pop good shot clock down to
three
Rubio has to pull Ed's hips that's a big
one for Utah and the team points on the
night none bigger than these three how
many percent number one overall
[Applause]
that cut lay it up and in
little confidence builder T Ricky very
active quick on his feet tonight
step-back three shot
flippy oh the role that with 22 key
Rubio got it rollin ice recovery here
catches a nice little opening touch in
tonight
Jose has been like in a boxing match of
this entire road tripping the stitches
above the eye - dislocated finger the
jammed finger on the right hand as Ricky
continues baseline six again on the shot
clock
Missouri's and it's up and in
Rubio quick seven and a quarter and time
it off the window Mason with the bucket
that comes Ricky with a left hand
Ricky Rubio has appeared tonight that we
have rarely seen Jonathan B now Davey's
going up the score Ricky there's every
shot we saw last night
he goes baseline hard and then turns and
puts it up reverse he does it's time to
time beginning is nice English on the
basketball kind of spins it get that
right hand gets the foul to great
there's no reason why we still can't be
very good defensively but we're there's
no question we're gonna have to borrow
differently as a circus shot with a left
hand by Rubio Donovan lost track of
Dwyane Wade on that one turned his head
and Blaine way put it down from the
three-point line
Rubio takes a seat gets a hand up after
the made bucket Ricky just doing a nice
job of getting that paint and here's
Ricky Crowder back to Rubio breeze on
the way
got it beautiful got it back and here's
Ricky got it back from Crowder and just
wasted no time you know if you don't
think there's two rebounds home-opener
bowling no moment right now
Sacramento is the season opener home
opener the Warriors O'Neill again talked
about it earlier their first nine games
their defense is really good their last
well
her if ik and tonight again the Divis
Spurs defense is not happy looks like
gay ball comes loose in the Jazz have it
you tall one Donovan leaves the way Joe
catch back out Rubio frees up bang so
far in this third quarter the three has
been Utah's best friend they knocked
down three threes including this one
deep by Ricky the bump out front no foul
Ricky thought about the three between
the legs
nine to shoot goes baseline against
Pirtle make it home
I love blasts and straight putting on a
clinic
Korver 18 Korver Thabo lays it up and in
nice pass to minute in favors wide open
look three sit down Joe it's an outside
ability and right off the bat how about
there is in this league so all on the
other side of favors and go bare you've
got to do the same thing here's favors
hitting that three Ricky with quite a
bounce in his step of late he'll go
baseline so TAS Rudi
[Applause]
Jess season-high for cysts and any half
is 21
Rubio ingles it's Rubio for three you
already see the rebound record get
broken today on Christmas Day
[Applause]
Rubio finds him again
[Applause]
right there Ricky Rubio with a great
decision just to commit a little bit I
gotta pay attention here that's Oliver
Hawaii leads away with 19 siakam 16 to
Toronto Ricky does that tough reverse
dr. Andros first buckin for Ricky
tonight and it means a lot on this trip
Ricky runs it in and scores still a
five-point game Bruce Wayne's up to
three how about the lucky bounce out
he's got to shoot it did not hit the rim
down by Rubio 21 hasn't held him and
check this far Ricky slides inside put
it down and one doing a nice job they go
Ricky
it goes Ricky hits the bump right to him
do the bear stands on his feet Lopez
who's good for seven three-point
attempts a game loses the ball Ricky
races to the rack and scores a layup and
the Jazz on the board with defense
Blazers have scored on seven of their
last eight possessions
Ricky inside
and on the other side Rubio off the
screen no one there lays it in here's
Joe Ingles he's been struggling with 24
points per game
Gobert the reigning Defensive Player of
the Year doesn't come out of the game
right here guarding the Joker nice nice
you just cannot give him that much time
to shoot that shot Crowder corner three
it's up bang good Crowder four in June
and he take a look at Crowder three wide
open look took his time to tee and put
it all for the Jazz went on there in
there pretty good to give them
themselves
capitalizing that time not a run that
goes all the way back to the second
quarter a great aggressive rule by Ricky
Rubio attacking the paint getting some
contact on the body then Bruce's
triple-t has seized an average of 5.3
ricky races baseline throws it up top
Rudy what hands it with the search
double get in the baseline right here
sees the big fella nice little pass
right up to him great timing 27 but
remember they have won nine of their
last seven Rubio goes inside first I
guess it missed England Joe brings loose
and the Jazz are on the board vo reaches
out rebounds leads it for Kyle tough
catch under control inside to Ricky Oh
[Applause]
get his teammates involved the reverse
layup 109 97 jazz 512 but Gobert ended
up with it either one it didn't look
pretty bouncing out to Ricky contact no
call shot balance Rubio those who his
left gives it to go bear on the roll
inside back out look at a blender
Rubio three up
[Applause]
guys could have taken that shot on the
rim and then this one was just beautiful
cuz four guys touch it Rubio and now
it's Paul George I'm Mitchell look at
Paul George taking the challenge is
saying if they're gonna I saw him I'm
the best kid on the floor let me go to
Rubio hits a three and then you're gonna
get to pick and roll action on the weak
side
Gallinari stolen ricky timed it
perfectly reached up here's Donovan
catch and shoot three up and yes so the
Jazz have held in check so Horace one is
three in the first half got a four point
nine
[Applause]
Ricky has found something now within
this clip of events great also Ricky to
his left off-balance shot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
whack he's getting found here and he
finds away they to not only draw the
foul to fade away please it for Ricky
just hit that 3dr bounce it inside
Rudy against Lopez Ricky free
[Applause]
by the Jazz have got the touch 21 years
no but I just this guy takes six and a
half threes a game I think he did last
year I wouldn't be surprised me to the
last year beautiful pass
but the Jazz lead by five with five
minutes left
Rubio left it for Gobert how about that
had it turn his back and reversed it up
an end beautiful layup by Rudy on the
other side nice pass by Ricky Rubio
holiday rolls it out Julius Randle on
the drive by Alfred Payton good hands
Ricky force that turnover once a ticket
to the remand does the tap for two Mike
Donovan he's over five here in the first
half and O'Neal runs it into frontcourt
[Music]
from Iowa State with a quick five here
in the second quarter that comes down
even for the high
skip finis it skipped twice in the
frontcourt what
[Applause]
are you kidding me what watch this this
drive right here it's a little tighten
up ball goes behind the back of the
Ricky Rubio I love you baby or the
beautiful play stays on the pivot back
at two Rubio nice move Ricky beautiful
right to left and finishes with the
layup
beautiful he just waited for the defense
to kind of go back to go where and
garden
and finishes well he blew by Tory and
princes Ricky with his left hand tries
agent boots and a foul to the offense
local passes and then getting Atlanta
scrambling defensible seat rail closeout
applause my strong rebound by Rubio all
behind the path heads all that's wicked
wicked
Ricky two favors 106 98 and as a
beautiful woman
bouncing Ricky - Donovan will drive
on past I should say and Ricki drives in
the first to go blank me with the bucket
to watch this Euro step dad's on the
great job is the ball inside seven
minutes left
seven minutes away from Utah for tea
fourth win so lately the value of
compare altering shots check it out
Rubio three did I behold it yeah I watch
that game last night I actually watched
it all the way throughout
[Applause]
you're right Rubio to his left
into the paint step back Jay shot
look at the rim right there these have
started over to the Ricky Rubio is
getting aggressive early on opens up a
lot for the Jazz it gets bump right here
this is their party try to coax the
other way what a contact off that drive
[Applause]
and goes for free yes the cappella you
have a great job right there 500 chance
and you're not going to get this nice
smooth by Rubio the Battle of the point
guards Rubio he can do it he needs to
keep his foot on the pedal and keep his
team in someone else to drive but then
you tuck turns it over Gobert trying to
hit ingles threw it right to harden but
then Rubio picks parties pocket alley
[Applause]
I think you will live with it you'll be
you'll live with the others other than
Chris Paul nice
Crowder beautiful one by Rho P oh you're
right he's gonna fourth assist here's
the slip-ons Crowder easy layin
it was the fourth quarter in Game four
we'd Rubio made this field
pass the ball ahead the Ingalls with an
easy two
what's up you guys this Taylor Brooks
with bleacher report make sure that you
subscribe for some more video content